whoopi goldberg has been making
headlines the holocaust isn't about race
no it's not about race because
it's about man's inhumanity to man
people are rushing to attack her no
whoopi goldberg the holocaust was about
the nazi systematic annihilation of the
jewish people who they deemed to be an
inferior race they dehumanized him and
used this racist propaganda to justify
slaughtering 6 million jews holocaust
distortion is dangerous enough
but wait mr greenblatt have you checked
your own anti-defamation league website
it seems to suggest that racism only
counts if the victims have dark skin
racism as the marginalization and or
oppression of people of color based on a
socially constructed racial hierarchy
that privileges white people i think
it's very hypocritical when they change
the definition of the so-called people
of color uh
definition they put out there and for
the ceo to come out and make that uh
statement against uh uber goldberg which
was clear she was wrong but she's
clearly aligned with what the adl thinks
and they should go back and do some soul
searching themselves before they jump
out and make a statement uh
against what she said because she's
definitely aligned with them should we
be worried about this new way of
defining racism i guess whoopi really
doesn't understand racism and how it
works she really wants to believe that
only black people experience racism why
else would she say that the holocaust
had nothing to do with racism i guess
jonathan greenblatt finally realized his
organization's definition of racism
matched what whoopi goldberg said the
brain rod that the ideal caused by
jonathan greenblatt is so complete that
everyone missed them changing the
definition of racism in july 2020.
this is long and indicative of how far
gone the adl from its original mission
the current environment in america and
maybe around the world or what they are
with the black race and the so-called
people of color and they kicking
everyone else to the side like their uh
struggle wasn't important or whatever
it's all concentrating on
on this so-called people of color and
black people at this particular time so
she's riding the band wagon with the
wide road you think everybody is on that
particular team which they are not
and i think that is where it carried her
and it's a mistake for her to follow
down that particular road when things
got awkward the adl changed its mind and
reverted to its original definition of
racism
racism occurs when individuals or
institutions show more favorable
evaluation or treatment of an individual
or group based on race or ethnicity
think twice before you follow the herd
it can lead to trouble